breaking news in Missouri where at least
two people were killed in a mass
shooting outside a nightclub police
surrounded the nine Ultra Lounge in
Kansas City around 11:30 last night it's
believed they met a male shooter was one
of those people killed more than a dozen
others were injured Savannah Rudisill of
our Kansas City affiliate that's KC TV
she's near the scene good morning kids
city police are still investigating what
led up to the deadly shooting right now
we have a handful of officers right
outside of the club earlier this morning
just a few hours ago we had dozens of
different officers from different
agencies around the area they were
hosting a sold-out celebration party for
the Kansas City Chiefs conference
championship and then the night turned
to chaos the shooting started when the
gunman fired into a line of people
waiting to get in line at the club we
know that two people are dead one of
them is the shooter police tell us that
an armed security guard took down the
gunman we know 15 other people have gone
to area hospitals three of them are in
critical condition police say there were
a lot of witnesses to this they are
offering a $25,000 reward for any
information that leads to arrest for CBS
this morning Savannah Rudisill Kansas
City Missouri